[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
ROBERT M. TOWNSEND:
Let's think about where
we are in the class.
You should have the
calendar in front of you.
So we're at lecture 7 today.
This is kind of a big
moment because we're fully
embracing general
equilibrium although you've
seen versions of it before.
The other thing would
be the reading list.
For today, there is not a lot of
new material on the reading is,
not a lot of starred materials.
We're going to do
Pareto optimality.
And the assigned
starred reading is
some of the sections
in Kreps, which
is available on the Canvas
website, so not much
additional stuff to read.
We're going to do risk
sharing at the end of it
and then look--
get in more into
the applications
in lectures 8 and 9.
In terms of the study guide--
so, again, let me ask
you a few questions.
We did dynamic
optimization last time.
And the first question is
really the motivation, but not
everything--
the motivation and the economic
problems we're trying to solve
are as important to the class
as the tools and techniques
that we're learning.
So let me ask you, what are
the observations on storage
on carryover of last year's
crop to this year's harvest that
motivated that lecture
that we did last time?
Wang Peng, can you answer that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] sorry.
ROBERT M. TOWNSEND:
Guanpeng can you
take a stab at this question?
What are the observations
on storage carryover
of last year's crop
to this year's crop
that motivated the
lecture from last time?
AUDIENCE: I believe the
observation was that it wasn't
necessarily that common for--
so I think it was
like the crops that
were carried over generally
there's two ways to use both.
One is carried over to
be planted for next year
and carry over for consumption.
ROBERT M. TOWNSEND: That's true.
Those were the two ways to
quote, "store the harvest."
Did they carry it over for
consumption very frequently?
AUDIENCE: I don't
think so especially
because the spoilage
rate was relatively high.
ROBERT M. TOWNSEND: OK, yeah.
So it was quite rare.
Carryover was quite rare.
And the purpose of the
model and its parameters
was to explain why
that would be the case.
AUDIENCE: Right.
ROBERT M. TOWNSEND: The
title of the lecture
was storage seed and starvation.
So do you remember how often
were they starving to death?
AUDIENCE: It was once
every decade or 12 years.
ROBERT M. TOWNSEND:
Yes, that's right.
Thank you.
Good, all right.
All right, so that was the
motivation for that lecture.
And then this question--
although I don't-- you won't be
able to write it down for me,
but maybe you can
say it in words.
What was the notation we
used for the return to seed?
And in particular, in what way
was it linear or at least up
to a limit?
And in which way did it
depend on uncertainty?
And let me see, Armando,
can you take a stab at that?
Are you there, Armando?
Armando?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Sorry, my microphone was muted.
Yeah, so there was--
I believe it was there was
three multipliers, right.
It was they each had a
random chance of occurring.
And it was like a poor
harvest, medium harvest,
and good harvest.
And it was just linear.
The harvest, the
amount harvested
is linear with how much they
planted with either a 1,
2, or 4 multiplier,
I believe, was it?
ROBERT M. TOWNSEND:
That's right.
Yeah, it was epsilon
times alpha times k,
where k was the amount
of land planted,
alpha was the linear
constant, and epsilon
capture those shocks you
just mentioned low, medium,
and high.
So that's a perfect answer.
Thank you.
So it's blending-- the
point of why I'm asking
is just to remind you that,
oh, because it's linear,
its constant returns to scale.
And yet it also incorporated
the uncertainty.
So we're going to come
back to that technology
when we look at
applications of risk sharing
in a couple of lectures.
All right, and this
next one, write down
a flow equation for consumption
in terms of the above notation,
but I can't expect
you to write it down.
So could someone
describe in words
what the constraint is onto the
problem in terms of this flow
equation?
I'll take a volunteer.
AUDIENCE: I remember
the consumption
is equal to the output
of the last year
input plus the output of
the inventory and a minus
how much you want to leave
for next year as the seed
and how much you leave for
next year as the inventory.
That was consumption.
ROBERT M. TOWNSEND:
That's perfect.
AUDIENCE: And the consumption
should be larger than 0, right?
ROBERT M. TOWNSEND: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: For each period?
ROBERT M. TOWNSEND: That's
another constraint, yeah.
This flow equation you
just described so well.
It's exactly what
I was looking for.
So to elaborate, we talked
about resources available today,
and that's the stuff
coming from current harvest
plus depreciated storage.
And then also, how much would
it be available tomorrow?
Well, that is co-determined
with consumption.
Because you have
available resources,
but you can use it for
consumption or you can save it.
And there were two
different ways to save.
So your answer was very
good, and I'm just repeating
in slightly different words.
OK.
I guess last one is principal
of dynamic programming.
This is a bit more technical.
But, again, I don't want to hide
anything from you, especially
when we subsequently
jump back and forth
between finite horizon and
infinite horizon problems.
Does anyone remember
how we converted
into two period problems?
AUDIENCE: So we
picked the last date
and solved the maximization
problem using that last date,
and then iterated to
the next last date
until we got back
to the first date.
ROBERT M. TOWNSEND: Excellent.
That's perfect.
And then the next part,
the infinite horizon part,
is we just keep going like that.
We just keep iterating, so
that the final terminal date
is so far away that
effectively they're
acting the way they would in
an infinite horizon problem.
All right, so that's
probably enough time spent
on those review questions.
Let me then turn to the
lecture today, lecture 7.
All right, so a brief outline
of what we're going to do--
we're going to define this
concept of various concepts,
Pareto optimality,
then Pareto frontier.
Then I'm going to show you a
programming problem, a math
problem so to speak, that
allows us to determine,
as its solution, all possible
Pareto optimal allocations.
And then we're going
to go and apply it
in the case of uncertainty
and call the solution
the optimal allocation of risk.
So although this slide says
utility possibilities set,
and that's going to be the
bottom line of the slide,
this is also a hugely important
slide for the whole course
because it's the first time, I
think, that we've introduced,
in notation, all the ingredients
we've been covering so far
and, in the notation,
describing an economy.
I went back and
looked at lecture 1.
It does say an economy is
preferences, endowments,
and technology.
We called it a PET economy
as a way to remember.
But here it is in notation.
So an economy, script
epsilon or economy,
is the consumption
set and preferences
of each of finite
number of agents,
the production set of each of
the finite number of firms,
and some aggregated
social endowment.
So it's a very succinct list,
preferences, endowments,
and technology.
Then an allocation
for the whole economy
now is an allocation x for each
of the capital I consumers,
an allocation in the production
set for each of the capital
J producers.
If we're in finite
dimensional Euclidean space
and there are capital L goods,
then we have L times I plus J
dimensional vectors here
belied by this relatively brief
notation.
In other words, we're going to
have to specify a consumption
vector Xi in the consumption
set for each consumer
i, a production plan Yj
in the production set.
It's capital Yj for each
firm j of the capital J.
And we say an allocation
is feasible if and only
if the consumptions are feasible
given resources available,
which would be coming from the
endowment and from production.
So a couple of
comments-- sometimes
people will write
consumption less than
or equal to as if you
could throw something away.
That's fine.
It's just more useful today to
talk about it as an equality.
The second thing is this
has buried behind it--
and it's easy to write--
all of the business we've
been working with respect
to negative and
positive elements.
So for example, some of
these Yj's are negative.
I refer to it as production
as if it were all positive,
like grain or something.
But if an input is
negative over here,
then there has to be
some offsetting element.
Namely, consumers supply it,
or it could be more evident
coming from their endowment.
So this is where
the accounting quote
of all the positive and negative
stuff is kind of buried.
But it is easier to
remember this way,
because it looks like
you just have resources
available from
endowments and production
meeting up with resources
used in consumption.
OK, now given the
same economy, we
can define the set of
all possible utilities,
utility possibilities set,
which is this script U
and which is a
specification of utility
for each and every household.
So this has the dimension
capital I, which
is the number of households.
And it's a vector
of that dimension.
And we're going to say that a
vector U bar is in this set.
And if two things are
true, first of all,
there has to be a
feasible allocation
generating it or generating
something with at least
as much utility.
So a vector over here, say, the
i-th component of this vector,
has to be able to be generated
by part of a feasible
allocation, which is
specifying Xi for household
i, which, when substituted
in the utility function,
generates a utility
level at least as great
as the target,
namely U bar sub i.
Again, it would be a
little more intuitive just
to put equality here.
But what this
allows us to say is,
if you can generate a utility
point through a feasible
allocation, then all the utility
points which are southwest
of it are also feasible.
So it's as if you could
throw things away.
So in words, this utility
possibility set is a set up all
utility profiles for households
in the economy that can be
attained by feasible allocation,
a feasible allocation with
greater than or
equal-- small typo--
so you can generate
v. In other words,
if you can generate U
and v is less than U,
you can have v in the production
possibility set as well.
Because whatever
that generated U
or something generating utility
greater than or equal to U
will generate utility greater
than or equal to v, all right?
So given a utility
possibility set, script U,
we define the Pareto frontier,
P of U, as the boundary.
So it's just the set of
subset of utility vectors
such that there is
nothing northeast.
If U is in the utility
possibility set,
there's no U prime
in there, which
would generate at least as
much utility for all households
i and strictly greater
utility for some households j.
So if the right
hand side were true,
then you could quote, "Pareto
dominate" the vector U.
And that would eliminate it
from being in what we want
to call the Pareto frontier.
So here's an example
and then a picture.
Let's simplify our economy
and get rid of production,
although we will
still have endowments.
So this is a pure
exchange economy.
There are only two goods.
And there are two consumers.
L and I are equal to 2.
And we're going to say,
for simplicity of notation,
first good is denoted X. The
second good is denoted Z.
So the first household has the
utility function over X and Z,
which is just linearly
additive in the 2.
And the second household
is very similar,
except it is multiplied by
2, but it's still linear,
additive, and so on.
Now, each has equal
endowment of both goods.
And the endowment
of household one
is equal to the endowment
of household two.
So 1/2, 1/2 everywhere means
there's 1 unit of good 1
in total, although it's
split initially equally
across the two households, and
1 unit of good 2 available,
also split equally.
So a feasible allocation
over these two goods
X and Z has to sum up properly.
So if we take the
first good and add up
what household 1 is getting,
what household 2 is getting,
it's got to equal the
endowment, which is 1,
likewise for the second good,
Z. What the first guy gets
and the second guy
gets in allocation--
it's not utility--
has to add up to 1,
the sum of the endowments, OK.
So it can be shown--
and I will show
you the picture--
that the utility
possibility set consists
of all points U2, which
are less than 4 minus 2U1.
And the frontier is just
the outer portion of that.
Without doing all the
algebra right now,
you can just
imagine, for example,
what would happen if we gave
the entire social endowment
to agent 2.
Agent 2 would then
get 1 here, 1 here.
And you get 2 plus 2 equal 4.
And you see this 4 down here,
which is the maximum utility
that agent 2 could get.
And the fact that it's minus
means moving away from there.
We're giving agent 1 some
of the social endowment
and taking away
from household 2.
And since 2's utility level's
twice that of household 1,
then every unit
utility that 2 gives up
counts twice for household 1.
OK.
So again, that's just to be
motivational without actually
going through all the algebra.
Here is what the utility
of possibilities frontier
looks like.
It's linear, again, with 4
over here as the maximal point.
This is a slope of minus 2.
It's negative because you're
giving up the social endowment
away from 2 toward 1 as
you move along this line.
What's not drawn in here very
carefully are the boundaries
of consumption and so on,
which if X1 and X2, Z1,
Z2 cannot go negative, then we
shouldn't be drawing in this
thing that extends
beyond the first orthon.
Pareto optimality,
this is the big one,
but it's almost obvious already.
An allocation x and y for
consumption and production
is Pareto optimal
if it's feasible
and there's no other
feasible allocation x prime,
y prime such that
the prime is at least
as good from every
agent i's point of view
and there's at least one
i prime household agent
that really likes prime better.
And we call these allocations
the Pareto set, the set
of Pareto optimal allocations.
Well, at one level,
it's kind of intuitive
that those should
be called optimal
because you can't make anyone
better off without making
someone worse off.
If you could make
everyone better off,
then it wouldn't be Pareto
optimal to begin with.
A little more telling,
this definition
doesn't give a darn about
the distribution of income.
So there's no normative
statement here about equality
and the income distribution
or anything like that.
So that's a little bit jarring.
We could give all the allocation
to household 2 and none
to household 1, and that
would still be Pareto optimal.
We can look at the
distribution of income,
and we surely will often
in the subsequence lectures
and in some of the
pictures about to follow.
That means, if you want to
talk about the distribution
of income and put some
normative criteria for that,
you're going to need more
than this definition of Pareto
optimality.
OK, so let's do a
two-person economy.
This is literally putting
the pieces together.
We did for households,
utility functions
and preference orderings.
And this puts consumer 1 with
two goods, changing the names
to a and b now, nice,
smooth, regular decreasing
marginal rates of substitution.
Oh, and household
1's endowment is
here, mark e, which means
a certain amount of good b
and a certain amount of good a.
So there are two
households, but we're
going to make this
guy stand on his head.
So the 0 point for
household b is here.
And more of good
b moves downward.
More of good a moves leftward.
So these are regular, nice,
smooth, concave, quasi-concave
indifference curves
preference sets
with more preferred to less.
And here's the endowment
of agent 2, boom, boom--
certain amount of good 2,
a certain amount of be,
a certain amount of good a.
You with me so far?
I think this came from
Kreps, but, you know,
the Edgeworth box is a
big part of economics.
Now, I'm going to
take this point e
and start moving this
whole figure for consumer 2
to the point that these two e's
correspond and are identically
lying on top of one another.
So that's like moving
this edge of what's
about to become the box
over in this direction.
And here, although e should
have been ideally put
on this picture, this
would be the Edgeworth box.
So now, we've got
household 1 down here,
consumer 2 here, and the
indifference curves of both.
The endowment, say, here, is
denoting the good a assigned
initially as an
endowment to consumer 1,
but the other
direction here is good
b being assigned to household 2.
So things add up.
The total adds up
except you're moving--
the amounts are signifying
different directions
for the two consumers because
consumer 2 is upside down.
So are there questions about
the construction of the box?
All right, so without putting
the endowment in there,
this would be red indifference
curves for household agent 1,
bluish indifference
curves for consumer 2.
I call them consumers,
households, and agents.
I'm not being consistent.
They're all called
consumers in this diagram.
And you can see these
indifference curves cross.
And I want to claim, going
back to the definition,
that this cannot
be Pareto optimal.
Why?
Because there are plenty of
other feasible allocations
that make at least one
household better off
and the other no worse off.
And in fact, there
are many allocations
that make them both better off.
This whole region here lies
above the red indifference
curve for household consumer 1
and above the blue indifference
curve for consumer 2.
Here, it's a different
picture where
the two baseline indifference
curves are tangent.
And in contrast, this
is Pareto optimal
because I challenge you
to find an allocation that
makes one better off without
making the other one worse off.
If you're going to make
consumer one better off,
you have to keep track of
these red indifference curves.
So we would be on or above
the red indifference curve
depending on whether
we're making them no worse
off or strictly better off.
And any of those points
other than the starting point
actually makes
consumer 2 worse off.
So now, we can
talk-- this is still
called Edgeworth Box,
although it's starting
to look more like a rectangle.
That's because there's more of
good 1 than there is of good 2.
It's wider than it is high.
And what's being
traced out here,
like this is from
the previous slide,
that there are many other
allocations which are also
Pareto optimal, where those
indifference curves are
tangent.
So this dotted orange yellow
brick road, so to speak,
dotted line, is a
set of all Pareto
optimal allocations
in the whole economy.
On the one hand, it's a
lot less, a lot fewer,
allocations than any
other feasible allocation.
Any allocation in
this box is feasible
because resource allocations
add up to the total endowment.
So [INAUDIBLE] worse off.
And again, you can see
these extreme distributions,
where, if we could go that far
to 0,0, consumer 1 over here
is in a terrible situation.
And consumer 2 just
got everything.
And that's feasible,
as is at this point--
feasible, also optimal.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
ROBERT M. TOWNSEND: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Does this [INAUDIBLE]
have some special properties?
ROBERT M. TOWNSEND:
Yeah, it's where,
in this sense with these all
smooth indifferent curves,
the marginal rates
of substitution
that we learned about are equal
across the two households.
AUDIENCE: OK.
ROBERT M. TOWNSEND:
You know, the reason
this isn't optimal is
because the marginal rates
of substitution are not equal.
So the amount that
consumer 2 requires
to maintain indifference, giving
up good a and getting good b,
is greater than what
consumer 1 requires
to maintain indifference in
terms of giving up good a
and getting good b.
So there's plenty of
quote, "gains to trade."
Both can be made better off, OK?
All right, now, I mean, one
thing we could have done
is put the endowment
point here and then
looked at the set
of-- well, maybe
imagine this is the
endowment point.
Then we could look at
the set of allocations,
which are Pareto optimal.
And that yellow brick
road would run like that.
And so these allocations
in the lens shaped region
are a subset of the Pareto
optimal allocations, which
make one or both agents
strictly better off
than at the endowment.
So that's a more refined
notion of optimality
called the core, which I didn't
create a slide to show you.
But that's sort of beginning
to take into account that you
can't make someone worse
off than their endowment,
whereas Pareto optimality, as I
keep saying, does not do that.
It's much more general.
OK, Pareto optimality and
the utility possibility
set, let's define, if
it's not obvious already.
An allocation of consumption and
production is Pareto optimal--
actually, it's a theorem.
We defined Pareto
optimality already.
And we defined the
Pareto set already.
So this puts them together in
a rather obvious way, namely
an allocation x, y is
Pareto optimal if and only
if the utilities that
are generated under x
are on the frontier
of the Pareto set,
which we denoted P script U.
So you can go both ways here.
It's if and only if the
direction from Pareto
optimal to being on the
frontier is left as an exercise.
It's pretty much as trivial
as the one we're going to do,
but we'll do one
of the many way.
So let's go in the
opposite direction.
That is we start with an
allocation on the Pareto
frontier, then we want to show
that it's a Pareto optimum.
So this is really
almost just a test
of remembering the definitions.
Suppose that it were
not Pareto optimal,
then we'll do a proof
by contradiction.
So if it's not Pareto optimal,
then there has to exist,
by the definition, some
other feasible allocation
denoted with a tilde
such that utility
is at least as high under
the tilde allocation
as it was under the
original and strictly
greater in utility
for some household j.
But then these vectors
of allocations Pareto
dominate the original one
and, hence, the original one
could not have been in
the Pareto frontier.
That's one way to
remember that is
that, if it's on
the Pareto frontier,
there's nothing northeast of it.
We just constructed
something northeast of it.
That's the contradiction.
So this direction is now proved.
And separately after
class, you can take a stab
at the other direction.
OK, so the moral
of the story here
is we can go back and forth
between the Pareto frontier
and Pareto optimal allocations.
And even I have to be careful
not to intermingle them
because I know it
principle they're the same.
And here's the
proof that they are.
Next step, we defined
a welfare function
for the entire economy,
and we make it linear.
So this big welfare comes
from the utility vector
across the individual agents.
And this welfare
function is linear
when it's just a weighted
average of the underlying
utility components
with weights lambda i.
Weights good in principle be 0,
somebody doesn't count at all.
Otherwise, the
weights are positive.
And when I say we take
a weighted average,
each of the weights might
as well sum up to 1.
Because if they
didn't, we could add up
whatever they do
total to and divide
through the same
objective function.
And if you're going to
maximize one welfare function,
you maximize the
scalar multiple of it.
So the idea of this welfare
function is a way I don't like,
but then I'll tell
you what I do like.
It's a way of aggregating
utilities across individuals
in society as if there were some
social planner who determines
who counts more than others.
And particularly under the
linear welfare function,
the lambda weights are the
weights on the individuals.
Now, what I do like about this
is this math problem, as it
were, which, if there
were a social planner,
we would be maximizing the
weighted sum of utilities
subject to allocations being in
the utility possibilities set.
So it looks like we've ignored
feasibility and everything,
but no.
The feasibility of
an allocation is
loaded into the definition of
the utility possibilities set
script U, and we're constrained
to pick utility vectors which
are in that set.
And we're going to
pick them in such a way
as to maximize this lambda
weighted sum of utilities.
And we can call that
the planner's problem.
So the big result is going to
be-- let me say it in words--
that, with certain
relatively weak assumptions,
any Pareto optimal
allocation that we pick
will be a solution to
the planning problem
for some weights lambda.
And any solution to the planning
problem for given weights
lambda will be Pareto optimal.
So the conceptualization
thing here,
before we get lost
in the notation,
is that we can now
go back and forth
between the notions
of Pareto optimality
and the idea of maximizing
the social welfare function,
although the weights can vary.
So let's look at the math.
Suppose we add a solution to
the planner's problem seven.
And just to make it easier,
suppose the lambda weights
are all strictly positive.
Then the first claim is
that solution to seven
must be in the Pareto set.
And if it's on the
Pareto frontier, sorry,
then it must be Pareto optimal.
Going the other way, if
the utility possibility set
is convex and
closed, then picking
any utility on the
Pareto frontier
and, hence, Pareto optimal,
we can find particular lambda
weights that makes that
utility vector a solution
to the planner's problem.
All right, so let's do
the two parts a bit.
For the first
part, suppose we're
given some U star that
solves the planning
problem at positive weights,
but claim by contradiction
that it's not on
the Pareto frontier.
Well, if it's on the Pareto
frontier, we can dominate.
There's a U prime vector,
which is no worse for all i
and strictly better for j.
But since the lambda weights
are strictly positive,
we've now found a new
vector, the prime vector,
such that the weighted
average of the prime utilities
is strictly greater than
the weighted average
of the starting point.
Hence, in more cryptic
notation, the dot product
lambda U is strictly
greater than lambda U star,
but we started with
the claim that we've
got a solution to seven.
And we just found
a feasible solution
to seven, which gives a
higher welfare number.
So that's a contradiction.
You with me so far?
OK.
So suppose that the
utility possibility
set is convex and closed,
and take some solution U
star, which is on the Pareto
frontier and, hence, Pareto
optimal.
Take a vector U star,
which is Pareto optimal.
It's got to be on the boundary.
And because it's on the boundary
of the utility possibility set,
in turn is convex, we can
apply something called--
and I'll show you
this momentarily--
the supporting
hyperplane theorem, which
is going to give us, guarantee
the existence of, a lambda
vector such that at that
lambda, lambda dot U star,
is strictly greater than
lambda U for any other U
in the utility possibility set.
In other words, lambda star at
lambda, the particular lambda,
lambda star U, is
the highest possible,
cannot be dominated by
in some senses weakly,
the highest possible lambda
weighted utility that you can
get running over all possible
other feasible utilities
in the utility possibility set.
That means that U star is
a solution to the planning
problem by definition.
So that completes the
proof of going both ways,
but it kind of begs
the issue of what
the heck is this supporting
hyperplane theorem.
So let me show
you some pictures.
And this is, along the way,
an extremely useful tool.
It's just the first time
that we've needed it.
OK, so here's the
utility possibility set.
Here's the U star
that we picked.
It's on the Pareto frontier,
so it's Pareto optimal.
And that theorem is
true, so I should
be able to find some lambda
weight such that, when
I maximize the lambda
weighted sum of utilities,
I would be at a
maximum at U star,
which visually you
can see is true.
There are other points
that are Pareto optimal,
but they would not be maximal
under the lambdas, which
are implicitly the
slope of this red line.
These are level curves.
We could call them
iso-welfare curves.
These are level curves
of the social planner
at particular lambda
weights lambda.
And it's kind of tradition
to denote the slope
by a line, which is right
angled to the line in question.
So this lambda going
up this way is just
a way to say that the
slope of both the Pareto
frontier and the
iso-welfare curve
are the same and equal to
lambda 1 over lambda 2.
All right, so that's a
picture of why it's true
that, when you pick a point
on the Pareto frontier,
you can find lambdas
which makes it
a solution to the
programming problem.
What is this hyperplane?
So we'll do everything in R2.
Here's a line in R2.
And in higher dimensions,
this is called
a hyperplane, fancy language.
You could probably draw
it as a plane in R3.
It gets harder to draw,
unless you're better
than I am, in R4 and so on.
But we'll stick to R2.
So here's a line.
It's called a hyperplane.
And we can obviously
talk about the half space
above the line and the
half space below the line.
So above the line means, if
we specify the intercept c
and the slope p then
the sets above the line,
the half space above,
is a set of all values z
which gives no lower value than
c at slopes p and vice versa
for the lower half space.
Here's another line that
separates these two sets.
We could call one of these
set A and the other one
set B. Note that they
are both convex sets.
Pick a set.
Pick the pink one,
pick any two points,
then weighted average
of those points
are, in turn, in the set.
This is a separating
line in the sense
that the half space
above this line
contains the pink convex
set is contained in that.
It's within the
half space above.
And the blue convex set is
part of the half space below.
And that's what all
this stuff up here says.
And the culmination
of this is called
the supporting hyperplane.
So again, we run
from hyperplanes
to separating hyperplane theorem
having to do with convex sets
to supporting
hyperplane theorem.
So this pick this set
B. And let's require
that it be a convex set.
Pick this point x in the
set and on the boundary.
Then the claim is we
can find a hyperplane,
in particular a supporting
hyperplane, which
just touches the
set B at x and is
tangent to the boundary at x.
Are you with me?
So the slopes of this
hyperplane are determined by p.
And we don't need a
constant c anymore.
This is said to be a supporting
hyperplane in the sense
that, if you picked any
other x in the interior other
than the one on the boundary,
any other y in this case
in terms of the
notation, it will have
a return which is less than--
p dot y will be
less than p dot x.
So this is what we were
using a moment ago, this
separating hyperplane theorem.
Because I kind of asserted
we could draw this picture,
and it seems really natural
that we ought to be able to.
It is using the convexity of
the utility possibility set
and picking a point, like
x was three slides away,
and then drawing this
hyperplane which is tangent.
And the separating
hyperplane theorem
says we can always do that
under these weak assumptions
like convexity.
That also means we can
pick another one, right?
If we pick another
point on the frontier,
we can find a
separating hyperplane.
But it's clearly, in
this diagram at least,
going to have a different slope.
So we can support it.
We're just going to have
to change the lambdas.
And that's what's going on here.
This was the initial point.
We could have picked
another point.
If we did that, we'd
have to find new slopes
for the supporting hyperplane,
so that it would kind of pivot
and allow it to be tangent at
this new predetermined point.
So again, not to
get lost, this is
how we're going back
and forth between Pareto
optimal allocations, which
are on the Pareto frontier,
and finding a lambda such
that at those lambdas
we would be maximizing a
linear welfare function.
And any Pareto optimal point
which is on the boundary
has to have that property.
And likewise, the
first part, which
was anything that is maximal
under the welfare function,
must also be Pareto optimal.
And the proof there that we
did was by contradiction.
All right, so in
notation, we can
parameterize Pareto
optimal allocations
by choosing Pareto weights.
And this lambda and delta sort
of means there in the simplex,
which, again, without
loss of generality,
the lambdas are non-negative
and they add up to 1.
We used simplex
earlier for lotteries.
Here's the second time
that we're using it.
OK, so if we want to maximize a
particular lambda weighted sum
of utilities, lambda
i weighting Ui,
we can do that and
find the maximum to it
and call the solution
X star and Y star.
But here, we're
going to earmark them
by lambda because it was a
solution at particular lambdas.
This is just a repeat of
consumption and production
sets and feasibility.
So any solution that maximizes
we earmark by lambda, this
is a particular Pareto optimum.
And also, given any
Pareto optimal allocation,
we can find a lambda
which makes it a solution.
So this is just
restating in words
what we already determined.
So the task of finding
Pareto optimal allocations
in the Edgeworth box is simply
solving this math problem.
So let's apply it.
Suppose we had this date
space with uncertainty
and this sort of, Debreu
tree about the set
of possible outcomes at
date 1, date 2, and date 3.
And we're going to
index consumption
by the history of
all shocks leading up
to that particular date.
And this was expected utility.
And this is a review slide.
We went over this last
time or at least earlier--
not last time, but
the time before that.
So let's determine an
optimal allocation of risk
in this economy that has
states determined at random.
So we're going to want to--
let me say it in words.
We're going to maximize a lambda
weighted sum of utility subject
to resource constraints.
Note we're not going to do
this in the space of utilities.
We're going to do it in
the space of underlying
allocations, but
it's the same thing.
Instead of going
from allocations
to utilities and from
utilities to maximizing
a lambda weighted sum,
we'll just kind of directly
search over the
underlying allocations.
It's small typeset.
You may be squinting
to try to see this.
Here was a repeat from the
previous slide, the utility
function, with a
little more notation.
So this is expected
utility as we
studied in the second lecture
on preferences and utility.
This counted by beta, as we kind
of did in the storage problem,
and weighting outcomes
by probabilities.
The summation here is over
all dates and all states,
as in this tree.
And then we take those
expected utility outcomes
and pre-multiply by
the lambda weights,
as we've now been trained to do.
And because we're
not in utility space
and we're in space of
underlying allocations,
we have to make sure
that consumptions add up
to the total.
Now, here's, again, a bit
of a switch of notation.
These Y's are now--
these right-hand sides are
using the Y for endowment, not
for production.
But it's not that misleading.
So we have an exogenously
given set of endowments
depending on the
data and the state.
And then consumption
has to add up to that
or certainly could not be
greater than that because it
would not be feasible.
So we call this
the Pareto problem
or the planner's problem
for, here, particular weights
lambda.
What does the
solution look like?
First of all, let me tell you
intuitively what's going on,
and then we can generalize it.
We wanted to maximize
the lambda weighted sum
of expected utilities.
All I've done here is pull out
in front of those expressions
the thing that is common
across all the agents i,
namely the beta and
the probabilities.
Otherwise, it's the
same expression.
But maximizing one is equivalent
to maximizing the other
because this is just
some scalar constant.
We also know that
consumptions are
going to add up to the total
social endowment, which
is the sum of individual
incomes, which
was I think I forgot to mention
at the bottom of this slide.
This is the aggregate.
Social endowment is just the sum
of the individual endowments.
So there's lots of dates
and lots of states,
but for every date
and state there's
a particular social endowment.
So we can simplify this so that
it looks like a static problem.
We can maximize each
component one at a time
and just respect the
resource constraint.
In the objective function,
a component one at a time
is just the lambda
weighted sum of utilities.
And this would be the
resource constraint
that consumptions have
to add up appropriately.
So amazingly, we've sort of
been able to abstract away
from dates and states and about
to determine an optimal risk
sharing rule as long
as we keep track
of the aggregate
social endowment.
Questions?
All right, so another tool we
can use that you already know
is the Lagrangian.
So we'll maximize this lambda
weighted sum of expected
utilities, and we'll
throw in the constraint
sets with Lagrange multipliers
where y is greater than
and is going to end up
being equal to the sum
of consumptions.
So these thetas are the
quote, "Lagrange multipliers."
And you can think of
them as shadow prices,
like the marginal
utility of income.
But there are lots
of them because we
have a theta for every possible
date and all possible histories
of states leading
up to that date.
So there's a large number.
Anyway, max away, we get,
for a particular date
and a particular
set of states, st.
We have the derivative of the
utility function with respect
to its argument preceded
by beta and lambda.
So we get this
thing, theta to the t
because it's at beta t
on the left-hand side.
And on the right-hand side, we
get-- where else does it enter?
Here.
So we pick up the
Lagrange multiplier.
And then this is just a
repeat of the constraints.
You could write it
out more formally
with theta times the
sum being 0 and so on,
but the problem is
implicitly assuming
that more is preferred to
less, resources are scarce.
So you're not going to
throw anything away.
These first order conditions
look like lambda times
the marginal utility of
consumption for household 1
is equal to lambda i times the
marginal utility of consumption
for all other households i.
And this is true
overall, for every i.
And this characterizes
solution for all possible dates
and states where the
aggregate social endowment is
a parameter.
So there are how
many households?
Capital I. So we have I
minus 1 equations here.
We pick up one
more equation here.
We can solve this thing
and denote the consumption
of household I to
be some function
g of the aggregate
social endowment.
This is a Pareto
optimal allocation.
It's certainly a
subset of the set
of all feasible
allocations, and it
has to do with these weighted
marginal utilities being
equated at particular
lambda weights.
Because utility
functions are concave,
strictly concave, if they
were strictly concave,
then this g is
going to be positive
with a positive derivative.
So there's a monotonicity
argument here
that, if the aggregate
social endowment is going up,
then the consumptions of
all the agents are going up.
How fast they go up as the
social endowment goes up
is a function of the g.
And the g has an i on it.
That i reflects potential
heterogeneity in the underlying
utility functions.
We did not require that
everyone has the same utility
levels or even the
same utility functions.
And I'll show you some
solutions momentarily.
So we'll eventually get to an
application, risk and insurance
in village India and
then one with production.
We will rederive this
equation and use it.
But the restrictions on the data
come from equations like 17.
Remember, economic science
is about making predictions.
So we have a whole economy.
Feasibility is one way to
restrict the prediction.
Optimality is a further
restriction on the prediction.
It's a criterion function,
a metric we're going to use.
We're now in the position
to make predictions
about what allocations
ought to look like at least
in this risk sharing setting.
And they have to
satisfy equation seven.
So there are lots of things that
are inconsistent with equation
seven.
And that creates a test.
We can go to an actual
application and start testing.
So let me just give
you two examples.
If we started with constant
absolute risk aversion--
and that concept
was introduced when
we talked about choice under
uncertainty under the consumer
preferences.
It's sort of negative
exponential, which makes
the margin utility positive.
This gamma j, which
is a weighting term,
is close to absolute
risk aversion.
Actually, 1 over gamma
j is risk aversion.
The higher this gamma j
here, lower this thing is.
So gamma j itself is the
inverse of risk aversion.
It's like risk tolerance.
And I'll spare you the algebra.
But if you maximized a lambda
weighted sum of utilities
subject to the aggregate
social endowment being e,
you would get this solution.
So this is saying
consumption of household 1
is a linear function
of the endowment.
This is the intercept,
and this is the slope.
The intercept has to do
with those lambda weights.
So very naturally, in this
case, the higher is lambda 1,
then the higher is
the log of this ratio.
And the higher will be the level
of consumption of household 1.
And the only thing left
is how those consumptions
will change as we change the
aggregate social endowment
determined over time or
randomly or whatever.
And it's saying that
consumption of household 1
will go up with e
at a faster rate.
And for household 2, the higher
is gamma 1 relative to gamma 2.
Gamma 1, as I said, is
like risk tolerance.
It's the inverse
of risk aversion.
So now, we're introducing
some randomness
in the economy's GDP.
And the issue is, who's
going to bear that risk?
Who's going to
suffer in recessions?
Who's going to bear the
bonus of being in a boom?
We have risk aversion.
So the guy that's most risk
averse with the 1 over gamma
would be the one where
this is close to 0,
meaning that his
concerns over consumption
is pretty stable against the
aggregate social endowment.
And the other guy is
bearing all the risk,
but that's a Pareto
optimal allocation.
The riskiest person
should bear the brunt
of the aggregate fluctuations.
Here's another example.
This is constant relative
risk aversion, a version
of which you saw before.
We're going to raise
consumption to the power d.
This is actually consumption
over and above subsistence,
as here.
So the consumption set has
a positive lower bound.
And this is the distance from
that subsistence consumption
raised to the power d.
And when you solve these
equations, they're linear.
And again, you get an
intercept and a slope.
However, it's a bit
different from before
because the intercept contains
not only the lambda weights,
but it contains the a thing,
which is related to the b,
related to the power in
the utility function.
It looks like higher lambda
is going to lower consumption,
but then you've got
to remember lambda
is a number between 0 and 1.
We're taking it to a power so
you can make it smaller instead
of bigger, et cetera.
So when you do it right
and think about it,
it does mean that higher
lambda 1 is associated
with higher levels
of consumption,
but it's weighted,
effectively, by risk aversion
and by the subsistence
level of consumption.
And now, if we vary the
aggregate social endowment,
the allocations will
change, but they're not
going to go up 1 to 1
the way they did before.
That's going to be determined by
both the lambda weights as well
as risk aversion.
Both those pictures, constant
absolute risk aversion
and constant relative
risk aversion,
look like this with
different slopes
and different intercepts.
And then this is--
I'm not and I probably should
have written out the underlying
utility functions.
But you can think of
this as one person having
constant relative risk
aversion, the other one having
constant absolute risk aversion.
And then you get
non-linear schedules,
but they are both monotone
increasing as predicted.
But now, the slopes vary and
the levels are clearly different
depending on the aggregate
social endowment e.
But we can still put
restrictions on the data.
So those are three pictures.
And we're going to come
back to these pictures
when we do one of the
applications, which is dividing
up land in medieval England.
We've referred to
the several times.
We're actually now
empowered with the tools
to be able to analyze
that application.
All right, are there questions?
OK.
So again, next Thursday
we're going to not
have another new lecture.
We're going to have a review
session over the first seven
of them, including this one.
So review the material, take
advantage of the opportunity.
Feel free to ask
me questions, and I
will try to provide
a summary of what
we've done so far in the class.
OK, thank you very much.